Primary elections are how political parties
in the United States pick their strongest
candidate to run for president.
The parties do this by holding mini-elections
in each of the states and the candidates with
the most votes from these elections becomes
the parties’ official nominees; these nominees
then face each other in the national election
for president.
But this isn’t the whole story. There are
five things that make it a bit more complicated
than that…
Complication #1: Primaries vs Caucuses
In every state, the local party leaders decide
how to run their elections. The two most common
choices are primaries and caucuses.
Primaries are just like standard elections.
Go to the polls whenever you can, stand in
a long line, hide in a booth, then tick a
box or press a button and your vote is cast
in complete anonymity.
A Caucus, however, is a public vote.
People gather in groups wherever space is
available then literally take sides in the
room with everyone else who likes the same
candidate.
The groups debate each other and, if people
change their minds, they need to physically
switch sides.
At the end of the debates party representatives
count the number of people in each group.
If you leave too early, you don’t count.
This description of primaries and caucuses
is really all you need to know but the specifics
can vary wildly.
That’s because there are fifty states all
of which hold at least two primaries and caucuses
for the big parties, and possibly more for
the small parties.
Covering all the local variants would take
a tediously long time which your short attention
span for boring political videos wouldn’t
tolerate – And you need to stay focused
because there are four more things to cover.
Complication #2: Who can vote?
In the National Presidential election all
American citizens over the age of 18 can vote,
with two exceptions, you can’t live here
or here.
But primaries are in-state elections with
lots of different rules.
Most states and parties will only let you
vote in the primary if you are an official
member of the party. This is called a closed
primary because the voting is closed to non-party
members.
But some citizens are independents – and
are not registered with any party. If you’re
an independent and live in a state with closed-party
elections, tough luck. No voting for you.
Some states, however, have ‘semi-closed’
primaries. Where independents can pick one,
and only one, primary to vote in. Parties
allow this because the presidential election
is often determined by independents so knowing
which candidates they like is useful.
Finally a few states and parties really play
it fast and lose with open primaries. Here
any citizen, no matter which party they’re
registered with, can pick a primary to vote
in.
But it’s not just the states that have primaries,
they’re also held in the District of Columbia
and the oft-forgotten territories – holding
primaries here is a bit odd though considering
that territorial residents can’t vote in
the actual presidential election.
Lastly are the Americans living abroad who,
depending on the party, vote in a bloc as
though they all lived together in one a big,
extra state.
When all these elections take place depends
on…
Complication #3 Who Votes When?
Primaries aren’t conducted all at once but
are spread out over a year. This leads to
fights between the states about who gets to
be at the head of the line and who is stuck
at the back. Inevitably, last minute leap-frogging
of dates happens – even though the parties
often take away votes from these uncivil states.
When it comes to being #1, nobody beats New
Hampshire who wrote it into state law that
their primary will always be at least a week
ahead of everyone else’s.
Which isn’t a problem until some other state
gets the bright idea to do the same and then
we have an infinite loop in our system and
have to force-quit the law.
But wait, you say, doesn’t Iowa already
go first? Yes, but New Hampshire lets them
get away with it for two reasons:
1) Iowa’s election is a caucus and so New
Hampshire is still technically the first primary.
and
2) New Hampshire thinks that Iowa is stupid
and doesn’t matter.
Other states try to boost their influence
not by cutting in line but by forming an alliance
and holding their primaries at the same time.
The biggest alliance of the election cycle
is called Super Tuesday where – depending
on how many states can agree with each other
– around half of them might participate,
giving out a whole pile of votes.
Which brings us to:
Complication #4: Votes That Aren’t Votes.
So this whole time you’re were probably
thinking that citizens give votes straight
to the candidates, but no.
Instead, the votes are given to a bunch of
guys, called delegates, who in turn will give
them to candidates as requested to. Maybe.
Depending on the state, delegates might be
required to vote as the citizens did, or they
might be completely free to ignore the citizens
and vote for whomever they want.
Who are these people? The delegates are local
party VIPs, such as state reps and officials.
The more citizens who live in a state, the
more delegates that state gets.
Later in the year, when all the states have
finished their primaries, the delegates travel
to a huge gathering for their party called
the National Convention.
It’s here that the official vote to select
the party’s nominee for president happens.
But it’s not just these delegates who do
the voting.
Complication #5 Super Delegates
Super delegates are the top members of the
party such as congressmen and former presidents.
They go to the National Convention, not to
represent the people, but to represent the
current party establishment and can vote for
whomever they want.
Depending on the party, the super delegates
might be up to 20% of the voters at the National
Convention.
Usually by the time the national convention
happens all the candidates save one have dropped
out of the race so the convention is just
a rubber stamp and a big party. But if the
fight between candidates is still ongoing,
the delegates and super delegates are the
ones with the final decision.
In summary:
Over the course of a year the states, plus,
DC plus the territories, and the Americans
Abroad hold their primaries, or caucuses.
When finished the delegates representing the
citizens who voted in those elections travel
to the national convention. Most of the delegates
are forced to vote as the citizens of their
state wanted them to, but some of them are
free to vote as they like.
At the national convention the delegates meet
up with the super delegates who represent
the best interests of the party and together
they make the final decision on who will be
the nominee for president.
Tired? Don’t be, because now the race for
the presidency begins.
Of course, you can skip all that and jump
straight into the election as an independent,
the only downside to this strategy is near-certain
defeat.